poor coronavirus is not letting up in
our state today we're seeing a rising
test positivity rate
21.5 percent now let's check the numbers
here on your screen
nevada is reporting more than 1 000 new
cases
50 more people have died here in
southern nevada 42
more people have died and only 700 new
positive cases
are being reported today our state's
coveted response team addressed the
numbers today they say delayed
laboratory reporting is causing low
totals and numbers will increase
tomorrow they also talked about contact
tracing and mentioned that neither the
uk variant
nor the south african variant have been
detected here in nevada
as for a discussion on the vaccine mega
sites like the cashman center
covett response director caleb cage says
they are pleased with how it is
developing
we're well within that process as you
know governor systec recently announced
that he
has directed state leadership agents
state agencies such as emergency
management and the national guard
to provide uh planning support and
resource support to help the local
district there are limited resources
in in vaccination in the vaccination
process but also in the testing process
and so as with any uh emergency where we
have
limited resources which in my
experiences is every
uh emergency um we will have to make
decisions the local
local jurisdiction will have to make
decisions
on what their needs are well caleb cage
added that governor siselek wants to
maintain the testing focus
at places such as the catchment center
but will also get the vaccine
distributed
as well